and so let's start with a
five minute game and i will only
only accept challenges from premium
members
so we start off with the sweet george
chakao unknown to me who that
is anyway we're going to play
a queen scam bit
and um i think i'm going to go for
one of the uh the a6 lines
basically the idea of a6 is the force
white to take on d5
since after knight c3 uh dc4
i'm going to follow it up with b5 and it
might be
a little bit difficult to win the pawn
back
white probably needs to go a4 now
as mr shakal quite correctly does
but now i i'm going to lose the c4 pawn
uh but i have
uh won a temple with beef b4 attacking
the knight on
on c3 um and it will be
the it's back uh presumably to to b1
yeah knight a2 is also okay
i i believe uh the idea
um with that being that you can
later reroute the knights uh to
to b3 and possibly a5 if you're allowed
after you've gone bishop d2 and then
knight c1
yeah now bishop d2 um i'm going to play
a5
obviously defending b4 a5
um is a little bit double edged however
um it fortifies the
the uh b4 point but it weakens the b5
square
which is going to be relevant after i'm
inevitably going to play c5 in order to
to challenge um the pawn on d4
queen c2 however is not a it's not a
good move
i should have started rerouting the
knight i think immediately
since now i'll get the opportunity to
severely
weaken um his uh
his pawn structure
now i also have a concrete threat as a
matter of fact
with queen b8 which attacks both
the pawn on h2 and threatens a fork with
with b3
uh so queen c6 uh is a good move
preventing
preventing that threat but i think i'm
going to play queen v8
um anyway winning a winning a tempo by
attacking h2 and then
later on i'm preparing castle
and uh he has uh has a pretty long thing
here which
i guess is justified uh considering that
his position
isn't isn't looking very rosy um
but yeah b3
um b3 i don't think helps
a whole lot so i could take on h2 here
but there would be some complications
after king g2
possibly rook h1 after castles
would love to go bishop h2 king g2
and then bishop f4 but unfortunately
that's not possible because of bishop f4
and then queen takes a8 also after
castles bishop f4
uh bishop takes h7 followed by
um by queen xd7 or maybe even quintex d7
followed by bishop h7
um would be an issue so i feel that it's
not only
more uh sort of instructive but also
may even be better just to castle so now
after bishop j
g5 i think um
yeah now it's safe to take uh
bishop f4 is gonna be my move regardless
of
whether it goes to h1 or g2 and
um uh no notice
how um the knight on a2
now now that he didn't um
[Music]
he didn't bring it into the game
immediately then
the uh knight on a2 may actually be
out of out of play for for a long time
uh bishop e2 i don't think this helps
his cause a whole lot um and uh
at this point it's uh pretty much a
mopping up
uh job yeah quincy one that's uh
that's a free queen and uh that does it
uh okay um not at all a bad game from
from my opponent uh it's 1300 um
[Music]
the the thing i would mention again is
the knight
uh that was stuck on a2 to until the end
of the game when you have
as they say when you have a piece that's
poorly placed your whole position is bad
that is at least sometimes the case and
in in this case it certainly certainly
was
was part of part of his his down